do you think most women have backup
plans
yes
and their DMs
oh you're talking about guys
yeah like you're in a relationship yeah
she's like I gotta switch and then like
a backup plan no no I mean like a backup
plan as a guy
he depends on who you're in a
relationship with I've had backup plans
in the past I don't currently have a
bathroom
so it depends how she views the guy yeah
yeah
this is honest
women don't need a backup plan y'all get
approached everywhere y'all have plenty
of
options
yeah we got approachable who are we
getting approach you getting approached
by somebody you like at some point
all you gotta do is go to the grocery
store I think men underestimate
they're in this
approached
person
not always by the best approaches but at
least like once every two weeks once
every two weeks
I mean I don't go to the clubs no there
we go it doesn't have to be a club you
can walk down the sidewalk
translation mean that she's interested
how many dudes walk up to you and flirt
with you is it daily
say slick comments at you how often does
it happen I mean it's got to be at least
daily pretty often but not but again by
people that I'm interested in that would
actually give my phone number to
okay
no but I do agree with you most people
most a lot of women that are good
looking attractive have you know their
life together you do get approached
pretty often especially living in a big
city even average ones and below average
they can approach I just find them like
guys don't approach in person as much
it's a waste of time now yeah no I
understand why but I'm just saying like
not in Brazil
[Laughter]
seriously Brazil needs to hire you
before we do something right what
percent of girls that you approach in
Brazil would I get 80 of the women I
approach what would you say in the U.S
yeah
like 10 to 20.
10 to 20. yeah it's a day are the are
the are the men there
because they're cap
I think the men are better looking and
the girls are uglier so it's like kind
of like do you think the men are less
good looking in Brazil no you have some
competition there okay
okay but uh women like to pretend
they'll give you a choosing signal here
and you go approach them and act like
they didn't know why you came over there
and I'm like dude I know I'm not [ __ ]
crazy but if you look at everybody like
that you know yeah that's why it's 20 so
20 percent
um
do you think men have a backup plan too
not the majority of men no do you think
the men that can have a backup plan yes
yeah
it depends on what you are what stage
you are yeah like most if you are
focused on your business you just ain't
got time for it yeah you really just
don't have time so either you go be my
girl or you ain't gonna be my girl
that's really that's really what it is
if I if if I see me who have backup
plans a lot of them there's something
he's afraid of he's insecure about
something and he's got to keep these
options because he might he might lose
them I mean who know they can go out and
go get what they want
there's no need for backup yeah you see
you think the ones that are more
insecure in their relationship
I think so maybe it's more of like a
she likes him for the money type stuff
um it could be a lot of different things
um it could be like he's outgrowner like
let's say they met when they were really
young and he's expanded himself and she
stayed the same and it just could be it
could be a number of different reasons
oh I actually have a question what do
you guys think about women that gain a
bunch of weight in a relationship
or lose a bunch of weight yeah yeah yeah
she's she's in last place now she's not
there's no kind of she's lost the
competition so she's more likely to be
cheated at all she's more likely to get
cheated on yes
what do you think do you think do you
think men will like should leave if she
gains a bunch of weight
and if she's like beared kids for you or
whatever is it are they married or yeah
no but he may cheat
and she should be able to understand it
yeah
in as much work I mean at least stay
healthy eat healthy want to work out for
your man and also like do small things
to keep that relationship alive and I
think it should be for both ways like I
don't want my man getting too
comfortable and getting thick like every
once in a while during the holidays okay
but you know like to keep that sex alive
I think it's really important on both
parties to to put in that work it's not
part of me it's common though isn't it
like I see girls get a ring all the time
and just blow up yeah no it is common I
think they both do I mean yeah yeah I
think it's very important for you to try
to maintain your frame when you even
just improve even just improve so I
wouldn't say it's grounds for cheating
but a conversation needs to happen but
now if she doesn't want to improve or
she doesn't want to change or she's
giving you push back then
I think a deeper conversation might
might have to happen I share the same
perspective and for a couple reasons if
you've got kids however the mama eats
that's how the kids are going to eat so
if Mama's unhealthy then the kids will
be as well that's what I said I I go as
far I think it's like child abuse if
you're gonna have your kid be obese yeah
like you're putting that kid at every
statistical
I don't know I think that's really wrong
I'd say it's more I want I don't want to
say it's more important but especially
young mama has to not you have kids you
don't gain a little bit of weight this
pandemic people right you do what you do
so it's not grounds to walk away
especially in the word that you use she
bore children that just put a whole
different level of sentiment on it and
she's got your kids but at some point
she's got to be healthy because if
Mama's not gonna be then the family
won't be yeah I think also too people
need to understand
um
like to
if you look at grandmother especially
within the black community
um and she from the shop she cooked a
certain way and so that just keeps
passing on and on at some point in time
it's up to us to do the research which I
think a lot of us have been and
sometimes you get pushed back because
they don't want to change it's all they
know it's uncomfortable for them to be
able to learn how to cook things outside
of their comfort zone where they say
things are nasty and that's why I always
push for parents to start giving their
kids water at an early age and veggies
they don't have to be nasty but you've
been saying this nasty so the kids are
gonna think it's nasty but if you if you
find if you see a light where there
where you guys can improve within the
family
then go ahead and bring it up and it
should give you push back that might be
a ground stuff for a deeper conversation
too because if you're trying to better
the family and the health of the family
why would you push back
just like a lot of women will take it
personal like I've heard from a lot of
guys that they can't like talk to their
girls about that stuff because they get
offended yeah they look at everything
like it's control the Earth's like an
attack on them like you don't find me
attractive anymore right yeah I think
that's the insecurity
I mean anything that makes sense it
makes sense to eat healthier like I also
want to become vegan like and I did it
for six months but I just want to just
leave vegan yeah oh God I could not do
vegan I mean that's what I'm leaning
towards I mean I just recently had food
poison a couple days ago and I was just
like what the hell are they now granted
it couldn't have came from me it was at
a kitchen the cocktails oh [ __ ]
but
[Laughter]
[Music]
let me get back on track
that's fine
we'll go ahead and move on
oh actually I saw this question on a
different podcast as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible